it is that time where we have to talk about
Joe Biden.
When we first saw that one or 2% of the vote
come in from the Iowa caucuses on Monday night.
It didn't look good for Joe Biden.
Now we have, as of this year,
[inaudible] 71% of the vote counted and it
still doesn't look good for Joe Biden.
Now with 71% reporting Joe Biden, based on
the current numbers, would get zero pledged
delegates from Iowa 241 state delegate equivalents,
which puts him in fourth place.
Now remember that Joe Biden was pulling in
second place going into Iowa.
These results are panicking, the democratic
establishment, because their goal is for an
establishment friendly centrist candidate
to be the nominee.
Those candidates were in order of perceived
viability before we got the Iowa caucus results.
The order of perceived viability for the centrist
candidate, it was Joe Biden, number one, Pete
boot edge, edge number two and Amy Klobuchar
number three, Biden with 71% of the vote counted
in Iowa.
Looks like he is losing badly to mayor Pete
and is barely ahead of Amy Klobuchar and meanwhile
the democratic establishment now has limited
time to do.
They want to switch horse in the democratic
primary and it's not just mayor Pete and Amy
Klobuchar that they are looking at.
Remember that Michael Bloomberg has huge cash
reserves.
There are even questions about does it make
sense for the Dem establishment to start pushing
Bloomberg in order once again to deny Bernie
Sanders or at this point it seems less likely
Elizabeth Warren, the democratic nomination.
There are concerns in the DNC about how does
Joe Biden justify raising money given his
results in Iowa.
His fundraising has been okay.
It's not been great, but if he does end up
in fourth place in Iowa where he currently
stands, why would establishment centrist Democrats,
whose priority is for burning not to be the
nominee?
Why do you donate to Biden instead of mayor
Pete boot edge edge does Michael Bloomberg
increasingly seem like the way to go for the
establishment because he has nearly unlimited
money.
Remember, Bloomberg has more than $55 billion
in net worth.
He spent, it's over a hundred million.
I don't know if it's approached or surpassed
$200 million at this point.
Biden's campaign reportedly has $9 million
on hand.
I mean, it's a crazy amount of money, but
it's almost nothing compared to what Michael
Bloomberg has already spent, nevermind what
he would be capable of spending without even
remotely affecting his financial situation.
So there are some donors who supported Hillary
Clinton in 2016 one example is Alex sink who
said people she knows are waiting to see how
Biden does in a couple more primaries before
deciding about giving Biden more money.
Fourth place in Iowa is not going to inspire
a lot of financial contributions to the Joe
Biden campaign and Biden AIDS previously said,
you know, he doesn't have to win Iowa or New
Hampshire because he's likely to do well in
Nevada and South Carolina, maybe a Bernie
Sanders of course doing very well in New Hampshire.
Nevada is now close.
Biden was barely up in the last poll, South
Carolina, still Joe Biden's strongest of the
first four, but one recent poll says Biden's
only up five in South Carolina and these polls
as we know are not always completely accurate.
So go back to the selling point for Joe Biden.
The selling point for Joe Biden to the extent
that there is or was one is that he's experienced
and he's electable.
Joe Biden's not exciting.
I hear very few people, even Biden supporters
say that Joe Biden is exciting.
Joe Biden's not bringing in a large cohort
of new voters who are planning to vote for
the first time and they want to do it for
Joe Biden.
That's not happening.
Joe Biden is certainly not progressive and
is not in line with what is increasingly the
point of view of Americans on more and more
issues, be it healthcare or many others.
It's the sort of legacy sales pitch, the legacy
statesmen of Joe Biden.
But if he can't win primaries, he was barely
viable in Iowa.
The case for Biden as the safe, reliable legacy
statesman from the Obama administration evaporates
very, very quickly.
So my question to you, where do you believe
the establishment will move if they move from
Biden?
Will they go to boot edge edge?
If indeed boot edge edge, uh, sneaks out the
Iowa caucuses, although again, it would be
roughly the same level of delegates as Bernie
Sanders.
Would it go to Amy Klobuchar who almost tied
Joe Biden in Iowa?
Based on the results we have right now, will
the democratic establishment say we should
go to Bloomberg?
He has the money for the long haul.
He is focusing.
Remember Bloomberg got zero in Iowa, but he
also didn't even campaign there.
He's skipping right to the super Tuesday States.
Where do you believe that the establishment
will go if indeed Joe Biden's viability remains
a question Mark?
To put it lightly, let me know.